I haven't done this in a while in case
you haven't guessed her good evening my
name is Betsy Brown and on behalf of
carla cohen and barbara mead the owners
of the store i'd like to welcome you all
to politics and prose this evening he
promises to be a fascinating evening
hearing about this book by david hoffman
who has worked for the washington post
since 1982 he covered the Reagan and the
first Bush administration's as a White
House correspondent and after stints as
a diplomatic correspondent and as a
correspondent in Jerusalem he became the
Moscow bureau chief from 1995 to 2001
he's currently working as a foreign
editor here in Washington for the
Washington Post and has tells me that he
wrote this book over a period of four
years on a lot of weekends and I just
hope you'll join me in welcoming David
Hoffman sorry we got a little bit of a
late start and thanks that everybody in
the politics and prose it's a really
beautiful afternoon I'm gonna try and
keep my remarks good in short allow a
lot of time for questions but I'm really
impressed that so many people are
interested in talking about Russia you
know I just came from the office where I
seemed to be talking about the Middle
East and Afghanistan I seem to spend a
lot of time worrying about Khanda har
and Kabul so I'm really happy to talk
about Russia actually it's fun and I
think I have a story to tell you the
story is this and the Soviet Union
collapsed the people of the new Russia
faced a really difficult problem Graham
Greene said a journey without maps how
do they get from failed socialism to
something approaching market capitalism
and especially could they have
capitalism without capitalists could
they have a capitalism without rules or
without the rule of law what happened is
they decided
they decided not by accident they
decided to have capitalists first and
the rules later so as you can imagine in
that free space of a couple years
without the rules the capitalist had a
hell of a time and this book is really
the story of six people who made those
decisions who made that happen and the
hell of a time they had we go back a
little bit in the book to where they got
their start and we go forwards all the
way up till today up till the sort of
wild and crazy oligarchic capitalism I
call it that Russia has today so I'm
just briefly going to talk to you a
little bit about some of the characters
in the book and a very very brief
shorthand of some of the major events
and so will you leave a lot of time to
take your questions
not Solzhenitsyn and I don't intend to
go on for thousands and thousands of
pages or hours but first of all I'd like
to just briefly introduce you to these
characters going from this side of the
book to the other Boris Berezovsky who
was once an applied mathematician
working a very prestigious Institute a
very small guy soft-spoken speaks very
rapidly and people used to call him a
compressed ball of energy because he was
a real organizer and hustler in the age
of Soviet science and next Mikhail
Khodorkovsky who was a young chemistry
student who became the richest man in
Russia today according to Forbes he's on
the top of the billionaires list and he
has a very very big and very rich oil
company next Vladimir Gusinsky who was a
failed theater director who essentially
was a guy who loved entertainment and
you know I think over time would have
built an entertainment Empire thought he
was a little bit Berlusconi a little bit
Murdoch and was trying to to fulfill
many of his dreams which were far
outsized considering the economy and the
state of Russia in his day after that
Anatoly Chubais as' was the longest
surviving of the Reformers and the guy
that made a lot of this events in this
book happened he's sort of the great
father of mass privatization and
privatization that followed he's the one
that distributed a lot of the goodies
that the oligarchs grabbed in the in the
1990s and we'll talk a little bit about
him Alexander Smolenski who was a began
life at the very bottom of Soviet
society very poor finally worked his way
up to be a construction crew boss and a
dump truck driver and had an ambition to
be a banker through a series of
circumstances became a banker thought he
wanted to actually build the Bank of
America and Russia had the largest
private commercial bank in Russia until
it collapsed in 1998 and finally Yuri
Luzhkov the mayor of Moscow a one-time
Soviet industrial manager who long
before others had ideas about markets
and market capitalism and loose cough
sorta got stuck halfway there he became
mayor but he didn't take the idea of
markets all the way he took him as far
as building his own empire in Moscow
sort of Richard Daley like and I
described in the book how that happened
but most importantly in this early
period you have to remember the Soviet
Union tried to repress all the impulses
of entrepreneurship of self-interest of
all the things that are part of a market
system I don't think they successfully
repressed those because they existed in
the shadows but I remind you that all
these characters who took Russia into
this new age got their start at a time
that we all remember bread lines
shortages a system that didn't function
and they were in the shadows of the
shortage economy and you know oftentimes
we wonder how two tycoons and magnets
make their money I think to understand
how these characters really made it in
Russia how they got rich you have to
realize they didn't start out in that
place called this mafia and organized
crime the stereotype is really not true
where they really began it was in a
place where you could make a lot more
money and that was in the shortage
economy in the economy of those bread
lines and I just like to give you two
very quick examples to illustrate this
the first one involves mister goose in
ski
he was a skinny young man with a big
leather jacket and he had those
eyeglasses that were very popular in the
Soviet period that stuck out way beyond
his head he was always smiling he was
very expressive but he had failed at
becoming a theater director and he was
driving a taxicab back and forth to the
airport just picking people up and they
stuck their hand out trying to make a
living one day he pulls up his taxi next
to a tram depot a place with these big
electric trams were parked overnight and
he noticed there was a huge bale real of
copper wire stashed in there which was
put there for the Transformers for these
electric trams he looked over the fence
as he was smoking a cigarette and he
thought you know I could do something
with that in fact I think I see a gold
mine back at that time Gorbachev had
allowed the very first private
businesses they were called cooperatives
and in the economy of shortage the for
the these new private business was
something very strange they were allowed
to make a profit they were allowed to
have their own self-interests does even
set their own prices
so mr. Basinski thought I'll start my
own business he got the reel of copper
wire for a couple bottles of vodka or a
couple rubles took it off to a defense
factory that wasn't working and he
realized that at that time in the Soviet
Union there was a fad the fad was small
copper bracelets so mr. Basinski
with a copper wire he had basically
gotten for free and a defense factory
had basically hijacked for free began to
stamp out copper bracelets they were
very simple they had two little dragons
on the end and the word metal in the
middle and he told me later that he
figured that each bracelet cost an
equivalent of 3 kopeks that's about 3
cents he sold them for 5 roubles or
about 5 bucks so he's making a big
profit on each one and he made a lot of
them he started to make 50 1840 copper
bracelets a day in that stamping machine
in the defense factory he was selling
them for 250
nine thousand rubles a day I just remind
you this was 500 times the monthly
salary of a Soviet doctor of science he
made his first fortune in that shortage
economy in that space of bread lines and
shadows and he's you know once he had
that money he started to think about how
to make the next fortune Boris
Berezovsky also got started in that
period he was a doctor of science at one
of those prestigious Institute's his
salary was 500 rubles but his great
dream was a car when he was 38 39 years
old he didn't have a car he had never
had a car you could wait ten years in
the Soviet Union just for the privilege
of getting a car car parts windshield
wipers headlights everything was in
shortage in fact if you weren't careful
people would steal your windshield wiper
blades overnight and you know if you
really weren't careful and you had a
good windshield some guys would come
along with big suction cups and they
just don't and they take your windshield
away and sell it so when Berezovsky was
thinking about making his first money he
realized there was an enormous shortage
of cars and car parts and in fact the
shortage was very real because he wanted
the car - now there was one very big car
factory and they made these boxy little
cars called the G ghuli or the Lada and
they made thousands and thousands of
them in southern Russia and mr.
Berezovsky went down there and what he
discovered was the car factory in the
late 80s in the period of Gorbachev's
perestroika was increasingly corrupt
really corrupt because there was such a
demand for the parts and for the cars
that thieves were making deals with all
the middle managers to steal the cars
this is quite sophisticated the deals
were such that the themes that actually
come into the assembly line and stand
there and put a sticker on every eighth
car saying that one's mine that one's
mine that one's yours nobody was really
making cars for the state here the
thieves would then drive their cars
outside the fence and there was a market
for cars and car parts all over town all
of them stolen the bribes were paid
according to the legends by the measured
by the centimeters high stack of $100
bills so if I pay you - that's a
2-centimeter stack of $100 bills
so mr. barofsky went to his car factory
befriended the director and made him a
proposal he said look you're being
ripped off blind all these small thieves
taking a hundred cars here 200 cars here
I'll make you a deal
give me 35,000 cars I'll give you 10%
down and I'll pay it all the rest in 2
years and look you get to give all the
cars to me you don't have to deal with
these small-time thieves anymore to be
much better for the factory and the
factory director maybe for a couple
stacks of those $100 bills said yes what
mr. Berezovsky knew was about to happen
however was that he had offered to pay
the factory back in rubles he got the
cars they were in big demand he sold
them for dollars he made a lot of money
on every car and then guess what
happened hyperinflation hit Russia the
ruble went from 450 to the dollar to
4726 rubles to the dollar the ruble
became worthless and with all that
worthless money mr. Berezovsky very
happily showed up one day and paid for
the cars
he got them practically for free he made
a hundred and five million dollars on
that deal so you can see that to be a
Russian oligarch
a Russian tycoon the first thing you had
to figure out was how do you out crook a
crooked system and that's the story of
how these guys got started I tell the
story later about once they started
collecting 10 million 15 a hundred
million they began to think different
they began to think not only about
getting a train load of cars a truck of
oil a lot of personal computers and
making a killing quick they really began
to think about how to steal the state
they began to think about how to get
political power they form a secret Club
they start to meet every couple weeks
they talk about who could be their
patron who and all of Russia could be
their leader who could be the person to
take them into the New World sort of be
their political frontman and of course
they don't settle on anybody's
small-time they don't settle on a
congressman or a senator or even a mayor
they decided why not force Nicolae
Yeltsin the president of the country and
of course that's what happens they get a
television stay
factories and they become very close to
in fact I would say sort of an informal
board of directors for Yeltsin Inc
they run the Kremlin they actually have
meetings and they decide who to fire and
and who to hire this is the story of the
90s but I'm often asked in discussing
this why did it happen why did Yeltsin
let these guys with their greed and
their ambition and their Millions run
Russia in that time and is it really
true and I think that there's a really
important lesson here and that is that
all of Yeltsin and all of his Reformers
experience had been in that Soviet
period of the big state of
authoritarianism you know and the thing
that they wanted to build was a
different kind of a state so they went
for freedom first maximum freedom first
and rules later
and that's what happened in the 90s with
these tycoons they entered a space they
came into being
they started banks and media companies
and oil refineries at a time when there
were practically no rules but not
because of an accident but because
that's the way it was that's the way the
founders wanted it to be and I just like
to finish up by saying that one of the
big questions that we face now in Russia
is after this first ten years I remind
you that the American robber barons had
fifty or sixty years to refine their
skills but after the first ten years
what happens to tycoons like this what
happens to robber barons who have grown
up and learned do they change do they
become Carnegie's and Vanderbilt's
Morgans and ghouls we don't know yet but
that's right where Russia is today it's
trying to decide just like to conclude
by reminding you of a story from those
air years of shortage it seems odd but
this is a story only from the 1980s it
wasn't that long ago when the Soviet
Politburo right after Gorbachev had come
in decided that they were going to
outlaw individual labor activity and of
course everybody scratching their head
saying what's that I mean is goose in
skis taxi is that individual labor
activity or what about growing your own
cucumbers and tomatoes I mean your own
garden is that individual labor activity
and they actually passed the law saying
in
new labor activity was going to be
illegal well you can imagine of course
there was no way to enforce this there
was absolutely no way to stop people
from doing this and they tried they sent
the militia out on the roads of southern
Russia where there were a lot of farms
with orders to arrest people that were
carrying tomatoes on top of their little
cars to the market and these people were
arrested said here this is individual
labor activity you're under arrest and
one of the big Russian newspapers had a
very interesting big expose about this
describing what was happening on the
roads and the headline was the criminal
tomato and Russia has come a long way
since the criminal tomato it's no longer
illegal or wrong to undertake individual
labor activity and entrepreneurship and
in fact what happened was a lot of
people made millions and millions of
dollars doing it without rules and now
the country has to decide where does it
go do those people evolve and become
Carnegie's imbalance or do we go back to
the criminal tomato so with that I'd
love to have your questions yeah sure so
you want me to do that whole thing again
your book in last week's financial maps
they did do you agree with this last
statement that your book is really
reported on the past
a different story than the
I think patient is all that over yeah
you know past is prologue I think that
my book is about the past but if you
want to understand Russia today you've
got to know where it's been
secondly I don't think oligarchy
capitalism is over it still exists the
players are changing the system is
exactly the same arbitrariness the use
of the prosecutor that you know I I
think the system is thriving
policy
you know it hasn't affected it a lot
what happened in that financial crisis
was Russia was just one of those
dominoes that fell and a huge amount of
highly leveraged funds like that
invested in Russia
I mean Oh most of they were investing in
stocks and bonds in Russia but you know
these things were going up 500%
it was very lucrative even the Russian
government bonds were going up one
hundred and two hundred percent a year
so everybody was trying to get in there
and invest in this hype and of course
when Russia crafts in 98 it took a lot
of people with it including including
them that wasn't the only country with
those problems but we've seen it happen
a lot of other places too I don't think
so I but I am find it very interesting
the outrage about a surrounding Enron
when we find out there are a few hidden
partnerships I think that people could
tell you you could just take a look at
the 90s in Russian find that there were
you know a whole lot worse things going
on and there are around the world we're
a rule of law state just imagine Enron
without the rule of law
we visited Russia about a year ago
Moscow were very interested in is this
mayor you write about is he the present
mayor yes Moscow yes could you tell us a
little bit of it when we were there was
just a may was a year ago and the May
June and we found it a most vibrant city
we we were just taken by surprise at the
life at what was going on and I wondered
if you could tell us me because we saw
it only on this very superficial level
what was really going on there
sure mayor Lou scoff I often think of a
sort of a combination of Mayor Richard
Daley of Chicago and Robert Moses the
great builder of New York because Lou
scoffs had a sense in which you could
harness money which bankers and other
people had and use it for the public
good and his entire idea was to not
necessarily to tax but she always say to
coerce the people with money to build
things for the city and this big new
cathedral I described in the book
bridges parks all that was built with
this money but it was not a rule of law
system instead it was much more a crony
based system where Lou scoff build an
empire with rich piles kicking in and if
they didn't kick in if you don't kick in
you don't survive you don't live the tax
inspector will be along so it's a highly
corrupt kind of structure it was not
very efficient it's certainly not
transparent Western or liberal but in a
strange way especially in this space
without rules in this wild and crazy
time of the 90s it worked for a while
remember Moscow has 75% of the capital
of the whole country all the major
companies were sitting right there
loose coasters had to say look you want
to operate today and tomorrow without
problems here's the bank account number
I expect your deposit it worked
one part of all this that still has
gotten some heat for the last year or so
has been the struggle between kasinski
is television station Putin and oil
company the journalists and so forth
what is your take on what was really
going on there and do you think this new
arrangement with peace that we have it's
going to work couldn't be anything what
was really going on here first of all I
mentioned Kaczynski was a man of dreams
his dream was to build this mammoth
television station and satellites and
everybody would buy his satellite
television very much like BSkyB or our
cable and that everybody in Russia would
have his television station his dreams
were just too big for what the country
could afford so he became very
vulnerable he borrowed heavily hoping a
little bit like any of our dot-coms that
you know the future would be as good as
the past and and the thing would work
and when it didn't happen that way when
the crash came in 98 he was very
vulnerable that's the first thing the
second thing is that mr. Putin is now
the president spent all the period of
Gorbachev and the great period of
perestroika in Dresden Germany when
people were learning about the Congress
of people's deputies and new freedoms
and new newspapers a blossoming and
mosque Putin wasn't there it's my view
that Putin believes that he can
modernize Russia and doesn't quite know
how but he doesn't want to create a
civil society in a democracy because he
does doesn't understand them he missed
that period so when he came to power
having never run an election never been
defeated or even elected at anything in
Russia he becomes the president he got
very fixated with television he told one
person that he actually wanted to
control what was on television every
night and who since keys television
station was the most rambunctious
independent of the state completely
outside the control the trembling so
what really happened here was Putin
decided I can't tolerate that that
shouldn't be it doesn't exist in my
world and he he went around and since
mr. buchinsky was vulnerable with all
that debt and squeezed them by the
throat calling in his loans prematurely
you know making it impossible for this
station to thrive and it went under
that's what happened it was political it
was political because mr. Putin wants to
rule without criticism Maui won this
deal puts the Kremlin in charge of the
station the journalists gave in remember
they lost twice they were kicked out of
two stations they finally gave in and it
didn't take more than a couple maybe
three days for the new head of the TV
station
mr. primakov to say you know we have to
have a little more self-censorship
around here as he said a couple days ago
I'm very pessimistic about the
development of Russian democracy no
history anybody else know even today you
know it's one of the great failures of
Russian reform was to create a banking
system that would actually make loans to
people most of these banks are just
essentially pocket banks in the pocket
of various industries and financial
empires
so mr. Smolenski who was the banker kept
building his banker bigger and bigger
and bigger was private it was commercial
it was actually popular his ATM machines
were in the Kremlin his cards were his
debit cards were used for all government
employees to draw the salary on it
looked like this guy was clear but
finally when the ruble crashed he got
caught out he had the biggest amount of
debts and his bank crashed one of the
interesting things is after the crash I
said how did you get in such a position
I mean why weren't you more careful and
he said you know it's not only the fact
that I wasn't careful
it's your investment bankers he said
those guys from JPMorgan they told me to
borrow 250 million dollars and I did
they told me because I could have it he
says I didn't need it that's what Russia
was about in the 90s
is it the only one of the oligarchs no
go since he also lives in New York and
both of them I think
but Putin chased him out of the country
but Horta coughs ki is doing quite fine
thank you he's got 3.8 billion dollars
in the bank from his oil company cash
you see any microeconomics coming up
like a Grameen Bank and you know just
grassroots banking not in banking it's
really tough there's lots of small banks
but you got to have a patron maybe
that'll change you know the head of the
central bank was just prematurely thrown
out and I think that's the very good
sign because he was essentially
preserving the old system what do you
think of the Moscow Times reports on
corruption in the last election Putin's
election you know I saw those reports I
actually thought they weren't that
persuasive did Putin win that election
fair and square I think he probably did
not but not necessarily by vote counting
corruption but by other kinds could you
comment on the role of American
investment banking or international
banking and also the role of some of the
kinds of advice that was given by our
experts and then a second question is do
you see when you say you're worried
about the future of Russian democracy do
you see any institutions developing to
deal with this kind of inequality of
power well yeah first on the West you
know we tend to be a little bit myopic
and want to look to ourselves to explain
the failures of some of the failures
what happened in Russia and we shouldn't
you know the Russians did this and they
did it themselves but we did make some
mistakes in the advice we gave them I
think there in some ways understandable
mistakes that you know you can't have
capitalism without rules we were so
excited and enthusiastic about the idea
that these capitals would appear on the
scene and the new Russian system that
we've you know we were over tolerant of
the long time it took to make rules and
I'll give you a great example it you
know the Soviet Union fell apart in
December of 91 the Russian Securities
and Exchange
Commission was not established until
1994 a basic regulatory institution in a
market economy took three years and you
know why they created a securities
commission not because they felt they
had to create that institution but
because there were so many guys selling
fraudulent pyramid scheme papers on the
street defrauding people that they
that's how they created it so it took
way too long where were we in all that
time we were being very enthusiastic
about sort of the the experiment and I
think everybody now agrees earlier focus
on institutions and rules would have
been good advice I also believe it was
impossible to flop it and make the rules
first you know there are people that say
have argued in scholarly papers why
don't you make all the rules first and
then bring the capitalist on well it
doesn't happen that way in real time and
I tell the story in the book I try hope
of how and why the reformers decided to
bring the capitalist on first it's like
a boxing ring you know if you're gonna
have a match what do you do first do you
bring out the boxers or do you build the
ring if you just build the ring you're
nowhere the Russian reformer said let's
bring on the boxers when they start to
fight they'll need rules that you know
they'll need a ring and they'll build it
well that's the that took too long that
took a decade and we still don't have
the ring puts it have from these
enormously wealthy and powerful all of
us
well he made a deal with them the deal
was everything you stole before I got
here you can keep and if you support me
you can stay if you don't support me get
out of the country so those that have
stayed have that allowed to keep their
oil companies and their factories to
prosper and they stay out of his way
that's the deal
but I argue that's continuation of the
old system you could say that there are
not oligarchs in Putin's Kremlin like
they were standing behind the curtain
manipulating Yeltsin that's true but I
think part of it is that they've drawn
the curtain tighter we just don't see
the manipulation
did you clarify something to me I
remembered how the banks
you know got pieces
I'm being asked about a very important
phase in which the oligarchs got their
property called loans-for-shares and the
chapter called the the embrace of wealth
and powers about that and this happened
in 1995 when as I said they were gaining
millions and tens of millions hundreds
of millions of dollars and needed to do
something with it and they made a big
loan to the state in exchange for
getting the best oil refineries and the
best metals mines that happened in 1995
Yeltsin was tired the state was
desperate and you know we can't forget
that throughout this whole period the
Russian state was very weak my favourite
example was the in fact that the state
could not even pay its militiamen the
guys on the street a pauper salary
they're paid months and months late so
you can imagine what kind of what kind
of place this is anything goes in
Yeltsin's period then there was a
oftentimes a story told about the
traffic cop you know the motorist has
summoned overt furn infraction he pulls
over and he rolls down the window and
the cop says hi my name is ivan father
of three
for centuries
no I didn't say it was new but it was
certainly a pervasive
where is that always positive
you know I got it I was on a radio
interview and and the interviewer asked
me I said you know didn't they make all
their money running guns and organized
crime and I said no ma'am I said you
know you can make a lot more money with
oil and I think that organized crime
existed and exists in Russia but the
real story here is that the big money
was to be made in that airless space of
a state without the rule of law taking
advantage of shortages and with things
like natural resources oil and diamonds
timber and platinum you can make a lot
more money and the organized crime was
really was really two-bit and small
compared to the fortunes we're talking
about
pootin I think for reasons I think that
you know for a guy who doesn't
understand democracy he does understand
the importance of rule of law he has
with a familiar friendly party in the
parliament passed a whole lot of new
important legislation so I've been quite
surprised at the degree to which he's
pushed for new laws on land ownership
new labor law and in fact there was a
new law on corporations passed I was
quite pleased the law took effect
January 1st everybody said this was a
really needed piece of reform
legislation and you know what happened
on January 16th the Kremlin using a
small subsidy of an oil company invoked
a portion of the old law to force one of
these television stations into
liquidation so a lot has to do with
implementation it's not enough to have a
brand spanking new corporate code you
also have to obey it and there the
jury's really out
it was first of all it was written but
then it had to be implemented by
arbitrarily from above by the party
right how would you compare this period
in Russia to our period in repentance
early 1900s when the Standard Oil and
the railway companies in all we're doing
exactly the same thing to describe
grabbing up everything they controlled
standing or control the total oil
company and they paid off a lot of
people to get it now what was the
difference in that period then in this
Russian period well let me tell you
about the similarities first the Russian
oligarchs actually studied this and one
of the one of the ways they study was a
Fame the Fiat our drives us both the
financier which was widely published in
Russia in the Soviet Union as because it
was considered such a sort of trenchant
story of capitalism and it was based on
a real American tycoon Charles York of
Philadelphia so one answer is a lot of
the manipulation of markets the stealing
the mechanisms that the Russians used in
the 90s were right out of our playbook
there's also a lot of similarities in
their way they carry themselves in their
lifestyles and the way they wanted to
behave that we're also right out of our
period so I think the similarities are
manifest there's one big difference you
asked about differences if you look at
the history of them say Morgan JP Morgan
really made his money as a bridge
between the British who had an enormous
amount of capital and American railroads
who had needed to expand but were just
too messy the British didn't get it
Morgan was the intermediary he could
tell them which ones to invest in and
not invest in and he would he was simply
a intermediary and you find that in the
case of Russia the structure was
different because there were no British
capitals all the capital came from the
state from the government and in that in
that way it made all the oligarchs
supplicants to political power and you
know crema the Kremlin represented not
just a fancy place with nice rugs and
and prestige it wasn't because they
wanted to go to the Kremlin ball that
they were interested in Yeltsin knows
because he signed the checks that's the
big difference
do you think is that a flipper
boating well for the future again it's a
big question mark its it's really hard
to say if it's a blip or not I would
like to think that it's not Putin has
absolutely no support or no base in his
own experience in his own country for
doing this and he's doing it but if he
wants to sit at the table there are
rules and sooner or later he's going to
realize that he's got to follow those
rules he hasn't followed them all in
Chechnya in the way Russian democracy is
developing so it's one thing to say I'd
like to be a member of your club it's
another thing to be one and we're
somewhere in between there the question
is about a claim that mr. Berezovsky
made recently that these apartment house
bombings that killed 300 people in
Moscow in 1999 were the work of the
security services and I just have to say
the jury is definitely out there's
really no evidence including the
evidence mr. Berezovsky offered it's not
very compelling but the fact is no one's
arrested you know nothing is done it
makes me very suspicious how influential
is he today not very the guy is on the
outside he's in London it sounds kind of
whiney you know and but on the other
hand he's a compressed ball of energy
you know if I were Putin I would not be
pleased that this guy was out there
bouncing around looking for ways to get
me and it would be a new experience for
the president to be a lame duck do you
think that the dynamics of politics
would change and am I correct in saying
that it's a two year I mean there's a
two-term limit two terms four years each
you know III think it'd be a disaster
for a Russian democracy if that were
changed and Yeltsin was on the verge of
changing it and who stopped him these
guys did and I often get asked to get
arguments well weren't the oligarchs bad
for Russian democracy - well they were
bad in the sense that they did believe
in
often times in completely corrupting the
campaign finance limits and things like
that they also did some good things they
created the only free really independent
press Russia had and when Yeltsin was
standing there right on the edge of the
precipice limit of the day he was going
to call off the election and do what you
just said
they got him not to do it it's a mixed
record
sorry no Kate ership by long did he
believe that well he said he wants to
establish a dictatorship of law
I consider that in oxymoron he also said
he wants to establish managed democracy
that's another oxymoron
tax police you don't want them to visit
you in the middle of the night I don't
think it's getting any better but it is
interesting Russia in Russia most of the
income tax revenue doesn't come from
people it comes from corporations but
the people maybe pay about 20-25 percent
of the revenues come from individual
taxes and recently in putin's effort to
modernize he cut personal income taxes
flat to 13% and this was a society we
all may remember in the 90s when nobody
paid taxes and now people are paying
their taxes it's a great experiment i
don't think it really means that much
for the future of the country because
it's not all that much money but it's
really interesting how people have just
decided to go legit and pay their taxes
when when he when he created a flat 13
percent tax rate
at some point a something stupid
the rudiments of
yeah but with with oil prices high and
oil revenue so high it's like you know
they're just swimmin in it right so
24/7
but nobody I mean there's just so much
tax evasion that it's hard and
especially small businesses which are
really important you know they're
constantly harassed and they try and
stay out of the way anybody else you can
drive two hours outside of Moscow and go
back a century and the amazing thing
about the whole experiment was that it
wasn't a progression where everybody
changed the same even in the 90s when
Lou scoff was using corruption to
rebuild Moscow you could drive two hours
and go back a century whole cities are
in distress I mean how could it be
otherwise did anybody think that this
was going to be neat I didn't what is
the corporate lending rate
I don't know there used to be just
sorry
what is the role for American
businessmen that are investing and have
big bucks up there now putting a lot of
money into are they they must be making
money out out yeah they're making money
but they're taking risks and I guess the
real question is is to let me give you
an example right gas promised the
largest company in Russia it's a natural
gas monopoly and if you just measure the
price of the shares of this company
based on the each barrel of oil
equivalent the hydrocarbons it's 25
cents a share by the same measure Exxon
is $13 a share same hydrocarbons why is
gas problem so low because the risks are
so great and you know the real question
about the future rush is where the gas
problem actually gets up closer to where
X is well but the risks are still even
at this day even when a guy says he
wants a dictatorship of law the risks
are so great that 25 cents is what a
share of that company cost now some
people say that's the cheapest place in
the world to drill for gas so you want
to take risks you know clock down your
your quarters and buy your shares but
lots of luck
the United States has just done two
things which it seems to me Russia's
gonna have to respond to her take
account of in some fashion one of them
is to withdraw from the ABM Treaty and
the other one is to demonstrate a
military capacity the likes of which
Russia can't even dream about is that
we've done those things yeah
Russia can't make that hasn't happened
if they can't just say well well I don't
see why not what choice do they have
what can they possibly can this week
poor country possibly do nominations but
they have accommodations that presumably
means that there's some real motivation
to continue but Russia has a defense
budget that is conservatively ten
billion dollars a year
ours is three hundred right what can
they do mattress and that's the whole
point I think the days of competition
are over I mean it's actually quite
pleasing to me so many people are
interested in Russia to come out and
talk about it tonight because if you
think about it Russia's in many ways
slipped away from the preeminent place
it had in our minds and our
consciousness for half a century and
maybe that's a good thing this
revolution in economics that I described
Happ was pretty bloodless it wasn't
completely without friction and war but
imagine it could have been a lot worse
periodically there's a lot of discussion
in the new Russia today about the great
idea or about some something to replace
communism and people have been searching
and trying and no this isn't it no this
isn't it nationalism seems to have
partly taken that place but what
comments do you have about what might be
let's say give some idealism to to
Russia well the search for new russian
ideas been going on for a long time and
Soviet socialism didn't really do it
certainly the bright communist future
how that plays
for a while but I think that at the end
people had given up on that one before
communism died I guess I would say to
you that it's not really very idealistic
but the chief ideology of the 1990s was
money money ruled and you can understand
in a certain way this sort of pent up
frenzied race that took place when all
bets were off when the Soviet Union
collapsed but money as an ideology is
not a very successful one certainly not
going to inspire people Russian
nationalism you know if I had to rate it
I'd say of the hundred percent of space
that's 20 percent it's and it hasn't
taken off it hasn't worked all the scary
nationalist politicians jaren offski and
leb and all the names are familiar with
what happened to them so I agree through
there's a vacuum I think if you look
through Russian history you'll always
find this vacuum and I would have to say
just based on my acquaintances in Russia
money became the great engine of
ideology in the 90s I know people had
two and three jobs who are absolutely
desperate and even zealous about making
it in this crazy new world that we had
tried to help them get started with
that's what it is I mean it's a lot
safer for us the through Russians be
interested in making money than making
war
Tobias and you know he was the longest
surviving reformer he stayed in office
when the others were discredited he
pushed he created the conditions for the
others to get rich he admired the
tycoons that he had created and he
wanted to be one and he's trying to be
one today so you know ultimately
everybody started to subscribe to that
in the Archie including Tobias get rich
I think so I think that Tobias was a
idealistic professor you know he read
Hayek and corn I and others who and he I
think his initial ideals were laudable
his ambitions were high but if you look
back closely at some of the things that
appealed to him if you can imagine from
the Soviet system someone said we're
gonna have an auction for property we're
gonna actually sell it to the highest
bidder and we're gonna have a
competition because they're not auction
as a competition three bids and they'll
be fighting each other he thought that
was wonderful in 1994 in 1993 but later
when the auctions turned into dirty
deals when people were rigging the
auctions when they were fixed when they
weren't clean he was for that too so in
some ways what what happens to Jew bias
is not corruption of the money kind but
corruption of his first initial ideals
that they wanted to allow so much pride
with you say
that it could not can go back no
question and they got so much 75 80 % go
to Belarus today go to Kazakhstan go to
Ukraine and look what happens when you
go slow in this race of the last decade
if you went slow you got stopped and
those that went fast made it the
farthest and now we have a lot of
evidence that fast reform at the
beginning is the way to get standard of
living up to get to growth and to get to
market economy and that slow reform
leaves you stuck in the doldrums and
creates even more corruption more
oligarchs and more problems never happen
just a lot of talk yeah there is
absolutely have you heard of a guy named
Oleg Deripaska Roman Abramovich no but
they're there they also got a couple
billion dollars each ones the aluminum
czar and another guy is an oil King
there's gonna be and I always thought
you know wouldn't it be better if Elton
had created 100 oligarchs what if there
were so many we couldn't put him in a
book actually seven or six wasn't so bad
but one would be very bad and I think
that the I argue that the era of
oligarchy capitalism will morph will
evolve into something more approaching
our understanding of capitalism but it
won't happen in ten years it could take
50 and a pluralism of oligarchs lots of
businessmen fighting with each other
competing for a piece of the pie that's
actually good for Russia and the
alternative which is being discussed
today in which some people think is a
alternative is the criminal tomato you
know one of the really interesting
questions is not one of them made it to
the cover of the book and you know you
could have guessed that one of the big
KGB guys would have actually fixed it to
get on into a book about getting rich
and Russian they never did a lot of them
we thought would be the new power
structure and they didn't they sort of
sometimes they took a little bit and
then they went to the Caribbean and
never came back
sometimes they decided it was too risky
because they were actually sort of risk
adverse they had never been in a
competitive
environment and for lots of reasons the
people that made up to Norman cateura
the Communist Party elite which you
might have guessed would have been the
new leaders of Russia actually fell
behind to the young guys who I depict in
this book and the it's a big mystery why
they let that happen
in fact I described how one of these
guys horikoshi took advantage of a
loophole which the nomic Authority
created for the young Communist League
for the youngsters the real sort of
communist youth group to experiment in
business and horticulture said that's a
great loophole thanks guys he never
looked back
why didn't he told me many years later
why didn't they take advantage of the
loophole well they were afraid they had
grown up in a system of fear horikoshi
wasn't afraid it's a pretty interesting
story well I know it's a different thing
I mean Putin didn't make a couple
billion dollars you know he was
appointed president of a country he
didn't even run for it until later
you know he's completely out of the blue
anybody could be appointed you me
okay
the questions about Viktor Chernomyrdin
who was the Prime Minister for five
years during this time who came from
gasp from the big gas company and again
you have to ask the question why isn't
he on the cover of this book why didn't
he make it to the top and again you have
to realize that people that had come
through the old system even the sort of
industrial managers of the old system
couldn't change fast enough you had to
be really fast on your feet to succeed
in this new system and he he couldn't he
was also in the government but by the
way that didn't stop him from taking a
billion dollars he formed a company that
did oil pipeline construction for for a
big gas company except they never build
any pipes and he put his daughter in the
company what do you think happened got a
lot of money and he didn't do any work
for it
all right you know you can argue that he
was an oligarch but I wanted to pick
ones that were more lusted above of the
era he's an example I think of a Soviet
era industrial manager who tried to make
it in the new system
you know there's not a lot of evidence
that they are but for example Horta
coughs key this big oil baron that I
mentioned realizes that all the
pipelines to Europe are full it's doing
a smart thing is building a pipeline to
China they're going to need all that oil
from Siberia all of the oligarchs have
international banking connections and
you know our jet setters around the
world but there isn't really much for
them in the former Soviet space you know
Ukraine definitely there so so gas deals
and defense deals to be made but for
them you know the big the big question
is energy raw materials and the demand
for well that's going to be China
well there are people that think that
China is gonna ice Iberia with a great
deal of envy in need and I think as far
as natural resources go if they can find
a way to transport them because that's
the big problem trying to become a huge
market for Turkmen and Russian gas for
oil and so on but you know the rest of
the relationship is practically empty
and we worry a lot about the
sino-russian cooperation but if you look
at it there is arms the russians sell
weapons to China and there's energy but
it's not even that big and they don't
get along and as a foreign editor of the
post I was criticized one day when Jiang
Zemin and Putin had a summit and they
shook hands and you know it sound like a
big deal and I didn't put it on the
front page and I didn't suggest it for
the front page because I didn't think
there was anything to that meeting it
was just for show and the next day the
New York Times put it on the front page
and everybody said you see you missed
the story but I would argue that it was
still for show nothing came of it and
then they haven't done very much with
you so I don't worry about it well what
does Putin have to offer Bush and you
know as Putin yeah I'm not sure they'd
be very useful you know I think for
Putin and for Russia the big issue as I
said before is can they clear the bar of
participation in in what we conceive of
as sort of the western you know system
of democracies and capitalism you know
in Chechnya can they change their
behavior you know when it comes to
welcoming foreign investment foreign
direct investment in Russia today per
person is $69 it's a hunter it's $1,500
in Hungary why why such a big difference
the risks are so great Russia has not
got Russian companies don't have
transparent accounts they're Enron and
you know until they essentially change
clean clear that bar they're not going
to get that investment and I think that
the people in the West are going to
still be a little bit wary but if they
do that allow a Free Press have
transparent a functioning system of
capitalism then I think they will make
it and that that's the choice for Putin
that's his choice
yes no great you know is this a test no
I did most of the interviews in Russian
so no you indication of transition
huge transition and it's interesting
because the Russians often said to me ah
maybe we should have done at the Chinese
way that's the Chinese often say you
know maybe we should hunt the Russian
way you know Russian went for freedom
first maximum freedom first free markets
and democracy and you can't eat freedom
and the Russians discovered that the
hard way they have a freer society than
existed in China and yet their economic
transition that has been more painful
but I would argue that the Russian
transition doing politics and economics
at the same time was actually was
smarter in the end history will
vindicate them however painful the
Chinese economic transition has been
slow but far more prosperous and it's a
different country they have so many more
advantages especially in agriculture but
it's a really fascinating comparison
between the two and you see today in
China issues of political Liberty that
are very comparable to early 1980s
Soviet Union where people for example
are not free to speak their minds except
under pseudonyms or not at all
you know things that we're going on in
the late Soviet period so you know again
you can't eat that but it makes a lot of
sense in terms of becoming part of the
world today
finish week a comes first
okay thank you all David Hoffman is
foreign editor of The Washington Post
his book the oligarchs wealth and power